long before Descartes famously declared
I think therefore I am
and long after that scientists and
philosophers alike have puzzled over
what they call the mind-body problem is
the mind some separate non material
entity piloting a machine of flesh or if
it's just a particularly elusive part of
our physical body how can it translate
the input of our animal senses into the
seemingly non-physical experiences that
we call thoughts but though the answers
have been debated endlessly new research
suggests that part of the problem lies
in how we pose the question in the first
place assuming a distinction between our
sensory perception and our ideas that
may not really be there the traditional
model of our mental function has been
that the senses provide separate data to
our brain which are then translated into
the appropriate mental phenomena visual
images into trees auditory experiences
into bird songs and so on but
occasionally we have come across people
whose senses seem to mingle together
allowing them to hear colors or taste
sounds until recently the common
understanding was that this phenomenon
called synesthesia was a direct
connection between the parts of the
brain responsible for sensory stimuli
such as seeing the color yellow
immediately upon hearing the tone of
b-flat but newer studies have shown that
synesthesia is actually mediated through
our understanding of the shapes colors
and sounds that our senses apprehend in
order for the cross sensory experiences
to occur the higher-level ideas and
concepts that our minds associate with
the sensory input must be activated for
example this shape can be seen as either
the letter S or the number 5 and
synesthetes associate each with
different colors or sounds based on how
they interpret it despite the purely
visual stimulus remaining identical in
another study synesthetes created novel
color associations for unfamiliar
letters after learning what the letters
were so because it relies on a
connection between ideas and senses this
mental phenomenon underlying synesthesia
is known as ideasthesia
synesthesia only occurs in some people
though it may be more common than
previously thought but ideasthesia
itself is a fundamental part of our
lives virtually all of us recognize the
color red as warm and blue as cold many
would agree that bright colors italic
letters and thin lines are high-pitched
while earth tones are low-pitched and
while many of these associations are
acquired through cultural exposure
others have been demonstrated even in
infants and Apes suggesting that at
least some associations are inborn when
asked to choose between two possible
names for these shapes people from
entirely different cultural and language
backgrounds overwhelmingly agree that
kiki is the spiky star while booba is
the rounded blob both because of the
sounds themselves and the shapes are
mounds make to produce them and this
leads to even more associations within a
rich semantic network kiki is described
as nervous and clever while booba is
perceived as lazy and slow what all of
this suggests is that our everyday
experiences of colours sounds and other
stimuli do not live on separate sensory
islands but are organized in a network
of associations similar to our language
network this is what enables us to
understand metaphors even though they
make no logical sense such as the
comparison of snow to a white blanket
based on the shared sensations of
softness and lightness ideasthesia may
even be crucial to art which relies on a
synthesis of the conceptual and the
emotional in grade art idea and asti's
'ya enhance each other whether it's song
lyrics combining perfectly with a melody
the thematic content of a painting
heightened by its use of colors and
brushstrokes or the well-constructed
plot of a novel conveyed through
perfectly crafted sentences most
importantly the network of associations
formed by Adeus Thessia may not only be
similar to our linguistic network but
may in fact be an integral part of it
rather than the traditional view where
our senses first capture a collection of
colors and shapes or some vibrations in
the air and our mind then classifies
them as a tree or a siren ideasthesia
suggests that the two processes occur
simultaneously our sensory perceptions
are shaped by our conceptual
understanding
of the world and the two are so
connected that one cannot exist without
the other
if this model suggested by ideasthesia
is accurate
it may have major implications for some
of the biggest scientific and
philosophical issues surrounding the
study of mind without a pre-existing
concept of self Descartes would not have
had an eye to attribute the thinking to
and without a pre-existing network of
interrelated and distinct concepts our
sensory experience of the world would be
an undifferentiated mass rather than the
discrete objects we actually apprehend
for science the task is to find where
this network lies how it is formed and
how it interacts with external stimuli
for philosophy the challenge is to
rethink what this new model of
consciousness means for our
understanding of ourselves and our
relation to the world around us
you